test où je tombe et rendent malade
shafia et moules est de nouveau sur les
sentiers de la campagne électorale mais
c'est une élection qui a un goût amer
pour l'élu municipal de saint fons en
banlieue de lyon après le premier tour
des municipales
elle a appris qu'une vingtaine de ses
colistiers bénévoles avaient contracté
le coronavirus elle même dit avoir été
malade
on est cinq hospitalisation et on a en
tout cas à l'heure actuelle on a eu
vingt cas de corona virus et 4 décès
liés à notre disent donc deux militants
ça j'en veux beaucoup à l'état je suis
très très en colère parce que le premier
tour ils auraient jamais dû se taire il
aurait dû attendre parce que là on est
en plein cowitz était pas possible
rachida une bénévole a dû être
hospitalisé pendant une dizaine de jours
il souffre toujours de douleurs aux
jambes et aux articulations dans le
quartier qui l'a vu grandir shafiei
moule est une activiste bien connu
distribution de denrées alimentaires
aide aux démarches administratives
la politicienne est désormais aussi à la
tête d'une association de malades de
lakovic 19 qui réclament la création
d'un fonds d'indemnisation
la cause c'est la cause quelque part de
tous les français qui ont été exposés et
tous les français n'ont pas à notre sens
bénéficier de la protection qu'ils
méritent
l'avocat hervé bambanaste constituent
des dossiers pour saisir le parquet de
paris et déposé plainte devant la cour
de justice pour mise en danger de la vie
d'autrui entre autres il représente une
vingtaine de victimes aujourd'hui et les
demandes continuent d'arriver sur son
bureau savoir comment et pourquoi ils
ont été contaminées parce que peut-être
qu'il n'y avait pas assez de masques
c'est le premier prendre et que si des
fautes ont été commises et bien qu'il
soit reconnu comme victime
ces recours de citoyens s'ajoute à une
longue liste de plaintes qui seront
examinées par les tribunaux dans les
mois et les années à venir voter le
premier tour des municipales a été
marqué par une abstention massive liste
qui est menée par shafia et mouiller
étaient à leur arrivée en quatrième
place
suffisamment pour passer au deuxième
tour du scrutin qui se tiendra le 28
juin prochain
je crois que je vais avoir très peur je
crois que je vais mettre à distance j'ai
pas vouloir comme approche j'avais très
peur les élus tiendra quand même un
bureau de vote dit elle cessons de voir
mamie ici marie-eve bédard radio-canada
saint fons en banlieue 2000